le cour des comptes annoncé hier
l'emballement des dépenses de santé les
arrêts maladie ont notamment augmenté de
11 % en un an
alors sans parler de ma la gym demade
imaginaire ou de médecins complaisants
les chiffres sont là et pour pallier le
manque de médecins agréés chargé de
traquer les abus à saint-etienne
c'est une entreprise privée qui vérifie
le bien fondé des arrêts maladie
reportage charlotte millet raphaël
jacquelin ce médecin généraliste
s'apprête à faire une consultation
plutôt spécial au domicile d'un salarié
de contrôler si savard est effectivement
médicaments justifié rodez l'escalier
loïc réveiller pendant sa sieste qu'il
est surpris par cette visite à
l'improviste en congé maladie depuis
juin il se dit trop stressé pour
travailler votre médecin
il estime quand même que vous n'avez pas
besoin de traitement de quoi parce que
c'est pour moi je pose en traitement
avant pour me regarder cacher un mélange
comme donc
là je dis je ne peux pas vous justifier
l'arrêt de travail au delà de 20 la
semaine
ce salarié payé pour l'instant moitié
par son entreprise moitié par
l'assurance maladie doit reprendre son
travail au plus vite
mais ces cas sont rares les fraudes
concernent surtout des gens qui ne sont
pas chez eux aux heures imposées par la
sécurité sociale en moyenne un cas sur
deux districts viennent de cette
entreprise stéphanoise en pleine
expansion avec un réseau de 1000 médecin
agréé en france
elle travaille en complément des
médecins conseils de la sécurité sociale
trop peu nombreux pour contrôler tous
les abus des abus en augmentation qui
pour elles sont liées aux 35 heures en
un quart des employeurs les gens se sont
retrouvées happées les 40 heures des
personnes qui en faisait 35 hésiter
moins disposés peut-être à passer sur
certains abus
en ce qui concerne les salariés se sont
retrouvés à faire le travail de 40
heures en 35 et je dirais que cette
double pression a fait que le moindre
petit conflit dans l'entreprise dégénère
et le problème semble de plus en plus
d'actualité cette chef d'entreprise a vu
son chiffre d'affaires doubler l'an
dernier